[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
hey guys so today we've got a special
episode where I'm actually addressing
the YouTube comment section I know I
know I'm insane for doing this so it has
come to my attention that some people do
not agree with my interpretation of how
late to II was actually able to become a
worm and I'm gonna basically explain why
I think I am 100 correct in my
interpretation and so here we go now I
say in this video that it is due to his
Benny Jesuit abilities that he is able
to undergo the transformation into the
worm God Emperor there were several
comments on this video with upvote
saying that I was wrong about this I'm
gonna explain why I'm not wrong about
this first we have to talk about what
are the Benin Jesuit abilities so the
mini Jesuit abilities include very
precise control of internal body
chemistry they can convert chemicals
within their bodies to other substances
they can choose the sex of their
offspring they can remove diseases from
their own bodies the mini desert have
these abilities due to Prana Bandu
training which they get from the time
they're very young now once a Benny
Jesuit sister undergoes the spice Agony
her full abilities are awakened she has
access to her ancestral memories and
this Wellspring of wisdom and knowledge
essentially AIDS her in everything that
she does says she has that much more
wisdom and knowledge about how to
control her own internal body chemistry
so now I'm going to read a comment that
has several upvotes telling me that I'm
wrong about my interpretation of what
actually happens in Children of Dune
later II didn't manipulate his body
chemistry when he put on the sand
drought skin he was so saturated with
spice at that point the sand trout
didn't recognize the water in his body
any more and reacted as though he were a
worm more or less so thank you for your
comment and I've actually gone into
quite some detail about several of the
things that you mentioned here in this
comment but we're going to focus on what
you said about lato did not manipulate
his body chemistry when he put on the
sand trout skin and that he was so
saturated with spice at this point that
the sand trout just recognized just
didn't recognize the water in his body
and reacted as though we were weren't
more or less that is incorrect but I
understand how people are making this
mistake in Reading Children of Dune
we'll start just by analyzing the quote
the moment in Children of doing when
later II first puts on the sand trout
skin and breaking down exactly what it
means
he felt the sand trout becoming thin
covering more and more of his hand no
sand trout had ever before encountered a
hand such as this one one every cell
super saturated with spice now this is
where people are getting this home
because he was saturated with spice that
that's why the sand trout were able to
do this I actually think that Frank
Herbert was just pointing this out
because if you read the next line over
it says
no other human had ever before lived and
reasoned in such a condition delicately
lato adjusted his enzyme balance drawing
on the illuminated sureness he gained in
spice trance now what does that mean
he's adjusting his enzyme balance that
is a miniature ability clearly and he
says drawing on the illuminated sureness
he gained during the spice trance
and that is clearly a reference to the
Benny Jesuit ability of other memory
that is unlocked when a reverend mother
goes through the spice agony
he goes on to say the knowledge from
those uncounted lifetimes which blend
themselves within him provide it the
certainty through which he chose the
precise adjustments staving off the
death from an overdose which would
engulf him if he relaxed his
watchfulness for only a heartbeat and at
the same time he Blended himself with
the sand trout feeding on it feeding it
learning it now you can see here that
late to II is manipulating his own body
chemistry and adjusting himself so that
the sand trout are able to blend with
him
to me this description sounds like
exceptional Benny jesuit's skill we spin
a good chunk of this book as well seeing
the lady Jessica train faradon in the
Benny Jesuit way and so much of this
crosses over now you could say that it
is not per se his many gestured
abilities that are giving him this
knowledge and ability but the fact that
he is a quiz that's had Iraq but
honestly I don't think that makes very
much a difference seeing that the
quizzes cataract is a product of Benny
Jesuit design now of course the Benny
Jesuit ultimately realized that they
could not control the quiz that's had
Iraq but that doesn't change the fact
that they did invent the quiz that's had
Iraq both quizzes Atarax Paul and lato
are born from a Benny Jesuit bloodline
so to me there really isn't much of a
distinction to be made there quiz as
cataract abilities are technically many
Jesuit abilities the quizet's hadarak is
essentially a more powerful Benny Jesuit
the most powerful biddy Jesuit in fact
later II in God emperor of Dune even
compares himself to the Benny Jesuit and
says that they are the most Like Him in
all the universe you cannot separate
quiz attack abilities from Benny jezra
abilities in my opinion and there are
multiple examples in the same chapter of
leito clearly drawing on Benny Jesuit
techniques still and here's an example
he fell into The Prana Bindu forced
relaxation Gathering his senses into a
pool of Consciousness now if you've read
Dune you know Prana Bindu is what the
Vinnie Jesuit called their very specific
kind of meditative training this Focus
the inward ripples of the constant now
through which he experienced time and he
allowed the vision Elation to warm him
the membrane worked precisely as the
vision had predicted
so this is a very clear reference not
even a reference it's an outright
statement of the fact that he is going
into a Benny Jesuit Prana Bindu trance
to achieve this and then in the same
chapter we have with a terrible
singleness of concentration he achieved
the union of his new skin with his body
preventing rejection no corner of his
attention was left to dwell upon the
terrifying consequences of what he did
there so again he is concentrating in
the Benny Jesuit way manipulating his
internal body chemistry to achieve this
connection with the sand trout So based
on all of this I do think my original
interpretation still stands late to the
second was in fact saturated with spice
but that wasn't the key reason he was
able to put on the sand Trout's skin the
fact that leito II was pre-born gave him
insight into the fact that the golden
path existed and he was able to go
forward with it by unlocking his genetic
memory and the Benny Jesuit way and
gaining access to all of that hidden
knowledge so for me that's pretty clear
let me know what you guys think of that
in the comment section below peace out
guys
so we've got some great news guys
Quinn's ideas officially has a Discord
now my goal is to make this Discord a
great place for all science fiction fans
to come and talk about science fiction
share their favorite books share their
love of science fiction stories and
Concepts while having a lot of fun I'm
really excited about this new way to
engage with my community and to create
more connectivity between my viewers I
hope you will join us over on Discord
thank you so much
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]